Cornered rats start to behave really a radically.
And that's what we're seeing right now with
the president as questions continue to grow
about Donald Trump's mental and physical health,
as his polling continues to collapse, as the
world continues to point and laugh at him,
as coronavirus tragically rages and kills
people in the U.S., despite many countries
having it completely under control.
Donald Trump has now, wildly and without evidence,
accused former President Barack Obama of treason.
Now, we've seen Trump now for a while go on
about Obama's supposed crimes.
Remember, Trump talked for a while about Hillary
Clinton supposed hate crimes.
That seems to have been forgotten.
And Trump even said not long ago that Barack
Obama committed the greatest political crime
in American history.
But when he was asked specifically what was
that crime, he had nothing.
That was then.
He has said now in an interview that aired
yesterday with the Christian Broadcasting
Network.
Yeah.
That the crime is treason.
Let's take a look.
Here is a visibly sweaty and disheveled Trump
casually saying the crime is treason.
The crime that Barack Obama committed is treason.
Also, the interviewer, David Brody, really
makes me cringe with his little interjections.
You can tell Brody is one of these suck ups
that just as desperate to be Trump's friend,
here's Trump accusing Barack Obama of treason
on Obama and the spying situation.
There's this idea that they were spying on
your campaign.
You've been asked before about what crime
he would have potentially committed.
But I remember you're talking of treason charges.
It's treason.
Look.
When I came out a long time ago, I said they've
been spying on my campaign.
I said they've been taping.
And that was in quotes, meaning a modern day
version of tapering.
It's all the same thing.
But a modern day version.
But they've been spying on my campaign.
I told you that a long time ago.
Turned out I was right.
Let's see what happens to him now.
Durham has.
I never met her because I want to stay out
of it because otherwise it's going to look
political.
But Durham, as you know, is a highly respected
person.
And Bill Barr is doing a great job as attorney
general.
Let's see what they come up with.
But they don't have to tell me.
Well, I have to do is read the papers.
The insurance policy in case she doesn't win
when we've got an insurance policy.
Well, that was all the stuff that we went
through over the last, let's say, two and
a half years.
Now, we kind of we kind of got struck and
page to two lovers, Brennan and Clapper, the
way they lie.
Democrats can't stand behind me.
They they just can't see in Whoville Bar.
They just think he's pulling.
You know why?
Because he's doing such a good job.
Because he's a law and order.
But he's got him in his crosshairs.
And now we have to see what's going to happen.
I will say this.
If it were reversed and if the other side
said, we're at the Oval Office right in that
chair behind the resolute desk, and it was
the opposite.
Two years ago, twenty five people would have
been convicted and they would be sent to jail
for 50 years.
So I want to remind you, we are experiencing
hyper normalization.
So I have to state unequivocally this is not
normal.
A president accusing a former president of
treason is not normal and it is outrageous.
Trump has possibly just months left in his
presidency, hopefully.
And he is focused on let's see what William
Barr comes up with on treason by Obama and
the Obama administration.
Now, just to give you a little context.
Treason laws in the United States exist at
the federal level.
There's also state treason laws.
The definitions are pretty similar in most
states.
The treason statutes are similar to federal
law, and it's about levying war against the
United States, helping the enemies of the
United States, giving aid or comfort to enemies
of the United States.
Only 30 people in history have been charged
federally with treason under those laws.
Extremely rare.
It's wild.
It's wacky.
It's embarrassing for Trump to say it about
Barack Obama.
They never actually had the goods.
And this is a continued sign of desperation.
Now, I want to remind you, here is what Trump
said when he was asked by The Washington Post's
Philip Rucker.
This was it was either three years or three
weeks ago.
It's hard to tell right now.
No, I think this was during the last four
to six weeks.
Philip Rucker asked Trump.
When you talk about Obama gate, what crime
are you alleging was committed?
And Donald Trump says, come on, Philip, you
know what it is.
Take a look.
Mr. President, in one of your mother tweets,
you appeared to accused President Obama of
the biggest political crime in American history
by hard for your words.
What crime exactly are you accusing President
Obama of committing?
And do you believe the Justice Department
should prosecute him?
Obama gave.
It's been going on for a long time.
It's been going on from before I even got
elected.
And it's a disgrace that it happened.
And if you look at what's gone on and if you
look at now all of this information that's
being released, and from what I understand,
that's only the beginning.
Some terrible things happened and it should
never be allowed to happen in our country
again.
And you'll be seeing what's going on over
the next over the coming weeks.
But I wish you'd write honestly about it.
But unfortunately, you choose not to do so.
Yeah.
John, please.
What is the crime exactly that you think?
You know what the crime is?
The crime is very obvious to everybody.
Well, you have to do is read the newspapers
except yourself.
A true classic moment of the Trump administration.
It's really, really terrible that it happened.
Right.
But, Mr. President, what is it that happened?
You know what it is?
You know what it is.
I guess now Trump is saying that what happened
is treason.
So now that we've got the sort of facts out
of the way, let's take a step back, because
I do think there's an important element of
hypocrisy to point to here.
And hypocrisy no longer matters to the American
right.
Maybe it never did.
As as as President Donald Trump has insisted
time and again he can do whatever he wants.
He can say whatever he wants to, whoever he
can do whatever he wants.
He can't be investigated.
These have been the positions of the Trump
administration.
Trump's entire presidency has been based on
the president can do whatever the hell the
president wants, period.
It's sort of a version of Nixon's.
If the president does it, it's not a crime
on steroids.
So if that's the case, couldn't Barack Obama
have done whatever he wanted while he was
president?
How is it that Trump can do whatever he wants
and can't even be investigated?
But William Barr can be investigating Obama
for treason.
Now, what Trump might argue is, well, I'm
a sitting president.
Obama is no longer president, except Trump
has previously argued this never should have
even been allowed to happen while Obama was
president.
And Trump, of course, believes he shouldn't
be investigated after being president for
things he did while president.
So it's complete and total hypocrisy.
Now, my question to you is, I researched this
today.
Couldn't find any examples.
Has any president in modern American political
history accused a former president of treason?
I wasn't able to find any examples.
I'm asking you for help.
If other presidents have done this, please
let me know.
And we will be covering this extensively on
the show's Instagram at David Pakman show.
Also, make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
If you want a break from the politics, I have
a picture of myself holding a teeny tiny puppy
over the weekend.
It's on my Instagram at David Pakman.
It's a beautiful message of peace loving and
understanding in tough times.
Or it's just a funny picture of you.
Be the judge.
The
David Pakman Show David Pakman
dot com.